yeah i guess three plus two isn't like
as popular as 3-0 oh hey i'm white
didn't i i said i was gonna be white
right
at some point let's go
what to play i'll play another e4
it was like whatever black plays i can
choose some some fun thing
i'll play another three
so i just played an alpine i could play
c3 and transpose into a pin
um someone was asking yesterday about
marathi bind
if i could just give a lesson on this
opening so c4
the intention is to play a morocci bind
structure
which is defined by pawns on c4 e4
and
wait a minute
this is move order
i think black was supposed to play d6
first
because now i have e5
like usually the line the idea is this
this
it's been so long since i've actually
studied this opening
um
[Music]
i mean there's knight g8 wait e5 night
sh8
bishop f4 d6
i can castle queenside even looks nice
wait a minute i was about to i was about
to play bishop f4 but before playing e5
the curse of my previous opponent the
same mistake that was made
yeah e5 first and now now bishop f4
and the idea is after d6 to castle and
create the pin
um and like at the glance this looks
really nice for white just
development central control space
but there are some issues with the queen
and pawn like pawns over extended queens
aligned with the bishop
so i do have to be careful knight's
ready to come in with tempo
i wonder if i can play queen d2 hit the
knight knight f5 and then g4
there's 9h4 threatening the fork and
then i castle
let's do it
because the knight has to move here
if i guess i could move here
but then i have queen e2 hitting the
knight defending the pawn
okay so we're going for this line which
i initially
looked at and this is really the only
move
it's pretty rare that you castle in
marathi mind
because i'm committed to c4 but
these are i guess extraordinary
circumstances
yeah what is the name of the opening
it's like sicilian
dragon marathi bind
some kind of accelerated dragon black
wants to play g5
i could stop it by playing g5 myself but
that gives away that f5 square
here's a cool idea to play e6 maybe
there's bishop g3 g5 f4
which is kind of neat
let's do it keeps initiative
and this doesn't scare me because the
night is just so loose
oh if i win this game i break 2500
okay no pressure
it's nice um having increments it's kind
of refreshing not
worrying too much about flagging
okay so now i'm just threatening the
pawn i just want to take twice oh no i
don't
if i take twice uh there's bishop h6
pinning
and winning my queen so i might just
want to play f5
yeah box aware of this trickery
queen a5 is logical
[Music]
maybe just bishop e2
i'm not sure what black's next move is
i'm just preventing this want to play
this move
i might just slow play like rook f1 king
b1
oh that's the next move
i should have seen that coming
um
[Music]
i really want to make e6 work
i take
95
yeah gonna have to live on the increment
so if takes i
think i just get away with winning the
rook
i have check here checking b1 i should
be safe
i'm probably more likely we trade queens
and then
it's hard for black to stop this move
might see takes takes castling and f5
takes takes
it looks nice
ooh
[Music]
okay so idea is to play f5 next no
matter what takes the pawn
oh if pawn takes i actually made in two
while
here here in the mate
okay so we're simplifying
is that just one big trade i think it
was
whoa it's money rosen's tea there once
was an i am chess guru
one could say that he knew chess voodoo
during one fun stream he said oh no my
queen
oh no and then he mated hikaru
i was not expecting that ending that was
great
thanks for the the poem was that a
limerick
that was a limerick right also thanks
for the ten dollars i appreciate that
my pawn da my
brook is getting weight i have this move
okay
what is this position we both have five
pawns
i have two pawn islands black has three
and the structure is solid
um
i didn't want to do that i wasn't sure
what else to do
so i want to get the king into f5 if
possible
oh it's going to be a race probably
i think i'm just faster because i win
this and then i'll promote
oh wait a minute
oh this is bad
or is it oh this is really bad
or is it
what's going on here oh this is really
bad
wait a minute i'm so i'm confusing
myself
no this is really bad
no i'm gonna lose this game
whilst i play this now
i'm winning black pre-move queen takes
bishop
i was flagged there too what is this
it's a miracle oh i
kind of feel bad but not really
that's why you never resign yeah so
black
saw there's a fork it made the very
understandable
like just pre-move assuming a king has
to move and takes a bishop
but and it crossed my mind that like
maybe
like queen f5 is pre-movable
which is why you should play bishop e6
here
man i was kind of
anxiety inducing ill sub for that
i feel bad for my opponent but thanks
john ludwig
screwdriver for subbing i appreciate
that
i feel bad a black played well that was
a
very elaborate game
also high youtube yeah should make a
high youtube emote
um yeah i really thought i was like
going to be faster here
appreciate it oh i appreciate you too
and zach appreciate that
yeah this pawn is really quick maybe i
had to play king f4
yeah king f4 and then the king can come
back and then i'll have two
outside passers and the king can't come
here because my bishop defends
if black goes for this king will retreat
the bomb cloud retreat sounds like a fun
vacation
so white should be better here
but yeah my opponent played well um
that was a weird opening though i'm sure
yeah okay i was winning here
so maybe opponent played well later on
in the game
um yeah opening was very nice
which is why yeah the main line is d6
oh carlson had this position twice
but yeah almost everyone plays d6 it's
very typical in sicilian
the reason to play d6 is to slow down
pawn e5
okay so if you're watching in the future
on youtube be sure to follow on twitch
i feel like by the time i post this
youtube video
i'll probably have crossed 100k
followers
but yeah if you want to watch on twitch
um you can follow and get notified when
i go live
also twitch chat says hi
twitch chat always so welcoming to
youtube
oh i received oh this was old choo choo
lol